Guy: Hi, everybody.
My name is Romain Guy.
For those of you
who don't know me yet,
I am a software engineer
at Google on the Android team.
I do a bunch of things.
I work primarily on
the application framework,
the UI toolkit,
the home screen,
and a couple of tools.
So if you have troubles
with your home screen
or some widgets,
it's probably my fault.
So you can insult me
on the--all public forums.
And today we're going
to talk about
how to improve the performance
of your UI
when the stupid animation
is over.
Here we go.
How many of you have had
performance issues
in their Android UIs?
Raise your hands,
don't be shy.
Okay, quite a bit.
So the rest of you, like,
you don't try the applications
or your code is perfect?
[audience laughs]
Just who--okay.
Who never wrote
an Android application so far?
That's good,
I like you guys.
Because now you have phones,
you can do that.
Before we start,
throughout the session,
I will give you some
numbers to give you
a better understanding
of how the various
tips and tricks
I will give you
will improve the performance
of your application.
Some of those numbers
come from recent experiments
I did.
Some of those numbers
are pretty ancient.
are, like, 18 months old,
so that's before Android 1.0.
So if I tell you
that the application
was running at
30 frames per second,
it's probably
a lot better now,
but at least the relative
differences will be the same.
And all the numbers
I will show you
were taken on T-Mobile G1,
to a prototype of
the T-Mobile G1.
And again, if you have
one of the newer devices,
it's probably better.
So this is our agenda.
We're gonna start with
one of my favorite topics,
the adapters.
So how many of you
have ever used
a list viewing application?
Okay, how many of you
like this view?
That's okay.
Wow, okay.
I don't.
Yeah, adapters can be
a big, big pain points
when you have a slow--
in your UI.
It's very often the bottleneck
of the performance
in the applications that use
lists and adapters.
So we'll see how you can
use adapters efficiently.
So first of all,
this is what I have to say
about adapters.
They're awesome because
they let you do many,
many really cool things
and they'll let you display
various items in the list.
You can create ListViews
in which every item
is a WebView.
If you do that,
I will be very mad at you
because it's a really
bad idea
in terms of memory usage
and performance, but you can.
You can also do
very simple things
like the contact application
where you have a simple label,
like a simple line of text
for every item.
Adapters are also
very painful to use
because they introduce
another layer of complexity,
another layer of abstraction
in your application.
And the documentation
kind of sucks.
That doesn't help.
But before you start--
before we start,
I would like to know
if you guys know how
ListView works.
How does the ListView use
the adapter?
Raise your hand if you think
you have--
you know how it works.
Okay.
Well, some are more courageous
than others.
I have a cool animation
that will show you how it works.
So the adapter, like I said,
is just--
Well, it's basically the man
in the middle.
So you have
your data source,
and the data source
on Android
is very often just
an array of data,
like an array of stream.
Or a cursor,
like the cursor is something
that we use a lot
on Android.
And then you have
the ListView.
It's the widget that represents
the data on the screen.
And the adapter is just
this little piece of code
in the middle that takes
the data,
converts it into widgets
that then--
that are then displayed
in the ListView.
It works very simple
like this.
But in practice,
the adapter--
the difference between
the adapter and the ListView
is very complicated.
So there's this method
called getView on the adapter
that you're probably
familiar with.
So ListView for every position
in your adapter,
so let's say you have
a thousand items.
For each item that the ListView
wants to display on screen,
it will call the getView method
on your adapter.
And the goal of this--
the role of this method
is to return a view,
a widget,
that will then be displayed
by ListView.
And getView sometimes,
very often in applications
that are poorly written,
will return a new view.
And creating a new view
on Android
is unfortunately
very expensive,
especially if that view
comes from an XML file.
Because you have
to inflate it,
which involves reflection
and tons of code is--
tons of code
is actually invoked.
So we can't really create
a new view
for every item
you have in the list.
Now let's say you have a--
you're a crazy person
and you have 2,000 contacts
in your address book.
If you want to scroll through
your list of contacts,
we really can't create
2,000 views.
Like first of all,
they wouldn't fit in memory,
but the time it takes
to create all of those views,
it might be that
50 milliseconds per view
will slow down the scrolling
by a lot.
So the solution to that
is recycling views.
And here I have
this really cool slide
that I had to create
three times
because Keynote kept crashing,
so I hope you will
appreciate it--
that shows how--
ListView recycle views.
So here we have a simple
skeleton of ListView
that can display seven items
onscreen at the same time.
And when the user
touches the screen
and starts scrolling the list
with his finger,
one item ends up
outside of the screen.
So what we do is that--
so ListView now needs
another item to display
the bottom of the list.
It could simply call
the adapter and say,
"Give me a view,"
and the adaptor could return
a new view.
But like I said,
it will be very expensive.
Why do we need to create
a new view
when we have this one
at the top
that we don't need
to use anymore,
because it's outside of
the screen.
So internally ListView
is this fabulous thing
that we call the recycler.
It takes the views
that are outside of the screen
and sends them to
the recycler.
Here you can see that
there are several segments
because in a ListView,
all the items can be
of the same nature.
They can be represented
by the same widgets,
or they can be represented
by different widgets.
So one item can be
a text view,
another item can be
a button.
And to do things efficiently,
the recycler is able to
make the distinction between
all those different items.
So here, our item was
the first type
that the ListView knows about.
So we put the item
in the recycler.
And then that item
is passed to the adapter.
So when we call getView,
there's a parameter
called convertView by default
that is actually a pointer
to that view in the recycler.
And when we do that,
when we pass one of those unused
views to the adapter,
the goal of the adapter
is to reuse that view
and simply send a text,
change the image,
instead of creating
a brand-new one.
So here, the adapter
turns out our old Item 1
into the Item 8,
and now ListView
puts it back.
All the items are left
unchanged,
and that lead--and that
allows us to have very, very--
performance scrolling.
So if you try to fling through
a list of ten items,
it will be the same amount
of work for ListView
as if you were scrolling
through
a list of 1 billion items.
So here's what
you should not do.
So if you wrote code
like that,
or if you have that kind of code
in your application,
you should--at the end of
the session,
you should go back to
your computer and fix it.
So this is the getView method
of the adapter.
So we pass the position
of the item that ListView wants,
we pass this convertView
we just talked about,
and the parent.
So the parent in this case
is always the ListView itself.
And in that case,
you can see the first line
of code in that method
I'm calling inflate,
to inflate an XML file.
That doesn't look like
a lot of work.
After all, there are only
four lines of code
in that method.
But again, doing that
while the user is scrolling
through a list of items
would be very expensive.
It will generate
a ton of garbage,
which will put a lot of strain
on the garbage collector.
The garbage collector
will then close your application
and you will see
the scrolling stutter
as the system is trying
to keep up with
what you are doing
in the adapter.
So instead of doing this,
do this.
Just check
if the convertView is null.
So if the convertView is null,
that means that it's probably
the first layout
in ListView.
So then you can actually
inflate the views.
You have to populate the
recycler the first few times.
So it's okay to do
this first inflation.
But if the convertView
is not null, just reuse it.
You are guaranteed,
if your adapter
is written correctly,
that it will be of
the right type.
It will be one of the views
that you created from
the adapter.
All right, so you can just
cast it to whatever view
that's supposed to be
in your adapter
and reuse its content.
So here, we're just setting
a couple of lines of text
inside--
a line of text
in an icon.
So the difference--
oh, in there, okay.
I'll show you numbers
after that.
Even better,
we came up with a--
we were working on
improving the performance
of the contact application
for 1.0,
and we came up with
this cool trick
that we call the ViewHolder.
So how many of you
have ever used this trick?
Okay, so some of you
are good and read the blogs
and read the sample code,
'cause it's actually in
the SDK.
There's an example of that.
It's called efficient
list adapter.
So I think it's kind of clear
what the sample is about.
Anyway, the idea of
a ViewHolder
is to minimize
the amount of work
in the getView method
of the adapter.
Most of the time,
your adapter--
even if you reuse
the convertView,
you will notice that
you'll end up doing
the same work
all over again.
So if I go back to
the previous slide here,
even if I reuse
the convertView,
I'm still calling findViewById
on the convertView
to get the TextView
and the ImageView
that were inside my item.
So do we really need
to do that every time?
We don't.
So the idea of the ViewHolder
is simply to hold some data
that's related to the item
to the view that's passed by
the ListView
and do the work only once.
So the way you use that
is actually pretty simple.
So that's our third variation
of the getView method.
We still inflate
the convertView the first time,
and the first time,
we also create an instance
of the--of this class,
the ViewHolder.
So this is how we call
this class,
but you can give it
any name you want.
Usually we like to call
the ViewHolder
so that we have a clear
understanding of what it does.
So you create a new instance
of the ViewHolder,
and you put inside
any kind of data
or reference that you need
and that you know
that you're gonna use
every time getView is invoked.
So in that case, we do
the findViewById the first time
and we store the result
of that method call
into the ViewHolder.
And then we store
the ViewHolder
as a tag on a view.
So a tag is any kind
of object
that you can set on a view.
It can be used by
your applications
to store some random data.
And in this case,
we'll just store a ViewHolder.
You're pretty much guaranteed
that the framework
will never use the tag
automatically,
except in Cupcake
on one particular occasion
which introduced a bug,
so my fault again.
But if you set something
in a tag,
you are guaranteed
that whatever you set
will stay there
and will always be of the type
that you just put there.
Now if the--
if we're past a convertView
that's not null, we need
to reuse that convertView.
So the first thing
we need to do in the L statement
is get the tag on the view,
which is our ViewHolder.
We cast it,
and then we can access directly
the TextView
and the ImageView.
At first, it seems like this
would not make that much of
a difference.
We're just avoiding two calls
to findViewById.
But when I ran the three
examples on G1 prototype,
this is what I came up with.
So the first example--
so the dumb adapter example,
the thing you should never do,
and if you're doing it,
then that's bad
and you should fix it.
We get less than
ten frames per second
when we try to scroll
through a list.
So that list in particular
was showing you one icon
and one line of text
per item in the list.
When you start recycling
the views,
you can see that the performance
becomes much better.
And in that case,
we get about 27 frames
per second.
And when you use
the ViewHolder--
so if you avoid doing
this to findViewById on every--
every time the getView method
is called,
then the performance goes up
even further
and will reach 37 frames
per second.
So just by using
this very simple tricks
that add just a few lines
of code in your adapter,
you can improve
the performance
by three or four times
very easily.
And again those are
very simple tricks.
So once you've done it once,
you'll understand
how it works,
and you will be able
to do it
every time really easily.
Now let's talk about
backgrounds and images.
Yeah, "Don't be greedy."
There is--
when you set background
drawable on the view,
you can set
the background drawable as a--
you can pass a drawable instance
that you created yourself.
You can set a resource
that comes from
your drawable directory,
or you can pass a bitmap
or color.
The background will always
fill the view.
That is, it will be
as large as your view.
Where it can become
a problem
is when you use something
like a bitmap.
So if you have a background
that comes from
a bitmap resource, that's--
that bitmap will be stretched
to be as big as the view.
Or as small as the view.
And the problem here
is that scaling a bitmap
at runtime is very expensive.
One of the reasons for this
is that we always turn on--
the bilinear filtering
by default,
which--you know, which makes
stretching even slower,
but it looks better.
And also because Skia,
a rendering engine,
is currently only
implemented in software.
So we don't have
hardware acceleration
that kind of operation.
So to avoid this,
make sure--
make sure that you pre-scale
your bitmaps.
If you know that the resource
you have will be stretched,
because the view
that you're gonna--
on which you're gonna use it
as a background drawable
will be bigger than
the bitmap, or even smaller,
do the pre-scaling first.
Pre-scale the bitmap
and then set it as a background.
And here,
I have a simple example.
I just set--
so the image
was 640 x 480 pixels large.
And I set it as the background
of my activity.
And then I was drawing
the application
as fast as I could.
So with the different version
that was scaling the bitmap
at runtime,
I can get 25 frames
per second.
By doing the scaling first
and then setting
the result of the scaling
on the activity background,
I get 50 frames per second.
So you can double
your frame rate
if you use bitmaps
correctly.
And pre-scaling bitmaps
is actually really easy.
If you have a handle
on the bitmap object,
you can actually extract it
from a bitmap drawable.
If you want to,
there's a GetBitmap method.
You can use the method
of the bitmap class
called createScaledBitmap,
where you pass
the original bitmap--
you pass the widths
and the heights
of the target size.
So most often,
you will pass the width
and the height of the view.
And the last--the last--
the last parameter should
probably always be set to true.
The bilinear filtering
I was talking about,
because it's a bit slower,
but it makes--
it gives you better results.
Window backgrounds.
By default,
all activities are in a window.
And all windows have
a default background.
So the default background
currently on the T-Mobile G1,
or on the device that you got
at Google I/O,
is just simple
color drawables.
We just fill the screen
with a single color.
And in some cases,
we don't really need to have
the background.
For instance, if you are writing
a maps application
and you have a map view
that fills the entire screen,
that map view is opaque.
Like you will never see
the background of the window
that's behind the map view.
Unfortunately,
the UI toolkit
is really stupid
in that situation.
And every time it has
to refresh the map view,
it will still redraw
the background of the window
even though you don't see it.
Again, totally my fault.
So--ahem--you can be
mad at me for that.
And actually,
it's pretty expensive
to draw the window
background.
The fastest background
you can draw
is a simple color.
Like it's a solid color.
So this is the default
background we have.
And on the T-Mobile G1 one,
because of the limitation
of the memory bus,
it takes about
3 to 4 milliseconds
to draw that background.
Which means that
if you're trying
to animate something
onscreen
at 60 frames per second,
you're really 4 milliseconds
out of the 60 milliseconds
you have per frame
to be able to achieve
that frame rate.
So a quarter of
your allocated time
is already going
into something
that's totally useless
for you.
So when you have
an application
in which you have a view
that fills the screen
that covers the entire window
background,
you can get rid of
the window background.
And the best way to do this
is to create a new theme
for your activity.
So in the--
You just have to create
the style--
the XML file in the values
directory of your application.
And this the exact syntax
to create a new theme.
The theme can be called--
can have any name you want.
Here I chose the name
"Theme.NoBackground."
And we inherit from
the default theme in Android
called android:Theme.
And the only item
that we have here
is a style for
the default window background.
And we use the special syntax
@null to indicate
that we don't want
any background on our view--
on our window.
Once you have your theme defined
in XML, in your resources,
you can simply apply it
to your activity
with the simple attribute
android:Theme,
and then the syntax
is @style--
and actually,
there is a typo in my slide.
It's no--it's not
NoBackgroundTheme.
It's Theme.NoBackground.
So the name is
Theme.NoBackground,
and here the theme
should be Theme.NoBackground.
And by doing that
you will effectively get rid
of the background
on your window.
And you will get
a better frame rate.
So here we have the version
of the application
with the background.
So we have about 43, 44 frames
per second.
And without the background,
we get up to 50-something
frames per second.
So it will highly depend
on the device you're running on
'cause it's mostly bound
by the memory bus.
But you can be--
you're guaranteed that
you're gonna get
a few frames per second back.
So if you're writing
a game, especially,
or a maps application
or GPS application,
something that will refresh
the entire screen very often,
remember to use that trick.
Okay, and some good news.
I just told you that
the framework is really stupid
because it draws
that window background
even though it doesn't need to.
As of three weeks ago,
the framework is not
doing that anymore.
It's finally a little smarter.
And that would be part of
the Donut release.
So in the next version
of Android,
you won't have to worry
about that.
Unfortunately,
users are still running
Android 1.1
and they're starting to get 1.5
on their devices.
So please apply that tip.
And also if you keep
using that trick
in Android--
on Donut, it will--
your application will
still run pretty fast.
It will actually even--
it will be even better
than what the framework does
because you won't keep
the background in memory
and you will save
a little memory.
Now let's talk about drawing.
So every time you want
to redraw a view,
you have to call a method
called invalidate.
It's pretty easy to use,
but it can also be
very expensive.
To give you an idea,
if you have a fairly reasonable
view hierarchy--
so let's say that
you create an application
like the contacts application.
When you call invalidate
on one of the widgets
on the screen,
it can take up to
3 or 4 milliseconds
for the framework to do
whatever it has to do
with that command,
and then comes back--
comes back to your view
and sends you the draw command.
Another issue
with invalidation
is that when you invalidate
several views at
the same time onscreen--
so let's say I invalidate
the view
in the bottom left corner,
and at the same time
I have a view
that's invalidating itself
in the top right corner,
the framework will take
the union of those two regions,
which will be pretty much
the entire screen,
and you will end up
invalidating
a lot more than
what you need.
So as much as you can,
you shouldn't validate
small regions of the screen.
To do this,
we have two methods
called invalidate,
and you pass a rectangle,
or invalidate,
and you press the coordinates
of the rectangle
to invalidate.
Those methods are part of
the API on the view class.
And they're really effective
to improve the performance
of your application.
If you invalidate just
a tiny portion of the screen,
the framework
will be smart enough
to avoid drawing anything
that falls outside of
this region.
And Skia itself,
the rendering engine,
will just ignore all
the drawing comments
that are not part of
this dirty region.
I actually have a demo
that shows you
how it can be using
the application.
So here I have the emulator.
And I'm sure you all did this
on the home screen.
So when you drag
an item around,
it follows your finger.
And the homescreen
has to invalidate the screen
to be able to draw the icon
at the new position
when you move it.
The first implementation
I did of that feature
was invalidating
the whole screen
every time you moved
the icon.
And the system was not able
to follow the finger.
The icon was lagging behind
because it was drawing
way too much.
So now,
I'm using this invalidate
with a rectangle,
and I'll show you exactly
what is redrawn every time.
So now when I drag
an icon around,
you can see exactly
the portion of the screen
that gets redrawn.
Everything else
is just ignored.
And what I just did here--
so if you go to the Dev Tools,
that's part of--
isn't that part of
the SDK?
Dev Tools.
Well, anyway,
it's either part of the SDK
or available somewhere.
You can--
[audience laughs]
Yeah, somewhere to be defined.
It's probably in
the source code
of the Android system.
Send me e-mails
if you can't find it.
So if you click that box,
"Show screen updates,"
every time invalidate happens,
you will see it flash
in this beautiful pink color.
And it's a really awesome
and easy way
to debug your application
and make sure
that you're not updating
too much on the screen.
So here, for instance,
I'm showing you something
that's really bad and drives me
nuts every time I see it.
So that's the new search system
in Donut
that I demoed yesterday.
And when I click
the search widget,
you can see that
for some reason
the entire screen
is being redrawn.
There's absolutely no reason
to do that.
So we have to fix it.
So please do use that feature.
It's pretty awesome.
But let me disable it,
'cause it's also pretty
annoying.
There we go.
Now to give you an idea--
so those numbers come
actually from the home screen.
When I was using invalidate
to redraw the icon
when it was following my--
trying to follow my finger,
I was getting about
18 frames per second.
And now that it's invalidating
only the icon,
the new position
and the old position,
we get almost 50 frames
per second.
So that--
the improvements
when you do these
can be pretty awesome.
And they highly depend on
the number of views
you have in your application.
So the more complex your UI,
the more you will want
to use that kind of trick.
Speaking of use--
okay, so that's one of
my pet peeves.
From time to time,
I go on the market,
I download an application
and I look at its layout.
I look at the number of--
number of views it's using.
And very often,
I'm really mad at
whoever wrote the application.
We do our best
to have a framework
that's fairly solid,
that has tons of features,
but that's also
pre-performance.
Unfortunately,
we're still running
on mobile phones.
And no matter what we do,
we have constraints
in memory, in CPU,
in memory bandwidth,
that kind of things.
And the more views you use,
the more views you put
in your UI,
the worse
the performance will be.
So if you have too many views,
the start-up type--
the start-up time
of the application
will be a lot longer.
It will take a lot more time
to measure
and load the application.
It actually can become
really bad
if you imbed several linear
layouts that can trigger--
each layout can trigger
several layout phases.
So you can end up--
just lay out the screen once.
Instantly, the system
might end up
doing the layout
20 or 40 times.
And also, the drawing would be
a lot slower.
And some of you may have
encountered an issue
if you have
way too many views.
If you have way too many layouts
in your view hierarchy,
you will even get
a StackOverflowException.
Have you guys ever run into
this issue,
the StackOverflow?
Yeah, one hand over there.
Behind you.
[audience laughs]
The stack, the default
stack size on Android
is currently 8 kilobytes.
That's not much.
So that means in Cupcake,
if you have about
14 or 15 embedded view groups
or layouts,
you will hit
a StackOverflowException.
The system doesn't have
enough memory to run the code.
We increased that size
in Donut
because we're introducing
new features that will--
that could prime
your applications.
But the point here is,
the more views you use,
the slower the application.
And actually,
sometimes it's not that hard
to remove views.
And also, it helps you
when you debug.
Like the less views
you have,
the easier it will be
to debug your UI.
So I'm pretty sure
that some of you
went to the session
this morning by Justin
where he showed
Hierarchy Viewer.
But I want to show you
that tool again.
That's something I use
very often.
So how many of you
use that tool
in your developments?
That's not enough.
Okay.
So Hierarchy Viewer,
let me show you
how it works.
I will show you the version
that's from our tree,
but Hierarchy Viewer is a tool
that comes from the SDK,
so you can just double-click
the Hierarchy Viewer executable
and you will get
pretty much the same tool.
So that tool works with
the emulator.
It also works with devices.
Unfortunately, it doesn't work
for security reasons
with consumer devices.
So if you have an ADP1,
or even maybe with a phone
that you just got yesterday,
it might work.
But if it doesn't work
with a phone,
you can just use it
with the emulator.
So here I can see
the list of devices
that are attached to
my computer.
I have only the emulator.
And over to the right side,
I have the list of windows.
So I can inspect any window
I want,
any application I want.
And it's by default.
I don't select anything.
It's gonna choose the window
that's currently
the foreground window.
So then you just click
the Load Viewer Hierarchy.
And this is asking the device
to send a dump
of the current UI
back to the tool.
And then in the tool,
you can get an overview
of what the view tree
looks like.
So that's the home screen.
And actually,
that's a pretty good tree
because it's very wide,
but it's also very flat.
What really matters
is that you don't have
too many levels in the tree.
If it's wide, that's okay.
Here at the bottom,
you can see how many views
you have in UI.
So here we have 39 views.
So that includes the grid
with all your applications,
all the icons that you have
on your homescreen,
your widgets,
all that stuff.
A good number of views
is usually between zero,
and you can
go up to 80 or 100,
but that's pushing it.
If you go above that,
you really, really
need to rethink your UI
and improve it.
And something we introduced
in Cupcake
to give you a better idea
of whether your changes
are improving
the application
is this little table
over there.
So those numbers are--
actually come from the device,
and they tell you how much time
it took in milliseconds
to measure all the views
in the hierarchy,
how long it took them
to do the actual layout,
and how long it took
to draw them.
So those numbers are not
perfect, 'cause if the device
is busy because there's a sync
happening in the background,
or if an application
is viewing the CPU,
those numbers will vary.
But it will give you
a good idea
and a good understanding
of what's going on.
And here, those numbers
are actually pretty good
but they should be
a lot better.
Having 6 milliseconds spent
doing a layout of
the whole screen,
that's actually really good.
But spending 30 milliseconds
drawing the screen
is not good enough.
That means you can't animate
at 60 frames per second.
So that's a really good way
to see
if you're improving your UI.
And usually what you want
to look for
in the Hierarchy Viewer tool
is places where
I don't think have
an example here.
But you want to look for
layouts,
a view group
that has only one child.
It means that one child
has widths of field parent
and the height
of field parent,
then you know that one of those
two views is useless.
So here, that could be
an example.
That frame layout
could be removed,
but that's actually
used by the framework
for many reasons,
so we have to keep it here.
But--so try to look for layouts
that have only one child
and try to get rid of them.
[muttering]
So once you've looked at
your layout in Hierarchy Viewer
and you decided that,
yeah, it sucks
and you have too many views,
you need to fix it.
And I don't know how
I did that.
There we go.
And here are a few solutions
we can use.
The easiest solution
is actually to use a--
what we call
the compound drawables.
I hate that name
'cause it's hard to say
for me,
and it's really long to type,
and it has
the worst API name ever.
There's a method on things
you call set compound drawable
with intrinsic bounds.
Yeah, you can laugh.
But the idea behind it is if--
if in your UI somewhere,
you have an image next to
a piece of text.
Usually how people do that
is usually a linear layout,
then they put an ImageView
for the image
and a TextView for the text.
It seems pretty straightforward
and pretty logical.
But that means that
you have three views
to just display an icon
and a piece of text.
So instead, you can use
this feature of TextView,
with its terrible name,
to replace the linear layout
of the TextView and ImageView,
but only one TextView.
So here, I have
a simple example on the left.
You see XML that produced
this tree here.
We have
a horizontal linear layout
and ImageView on the left,
and a piece of text
on the right.
And the equivalent to this
is the XML on the right.
So it's pretty much
the same TextView
except we use this attribute
called drawableLeft
that will simply set
a bitmap
on the left side of the text.
You can also set bitmaps
above the text,
below the text,
and on the right.
And you can set four bitmaps
at the same time
if for some reason
you need to do this.
So it's very easy to do,
very efficient way to improve
your UIs.
Now, the ViewStub.
How many of you ever used
a ViewStub
or even know what it is?
Okay.
That's not enough.
You guys should, you know,
read the docs.
Well, the docs that we wrote.
Um...
[audience laughs]
Hey, we're working on it.
So the idea of a ViewStub
is whenever you have a UI
in which there's
a part of the UI
that you don't show
very often--
I'm sure you've all used,
like, the invisible mode
or the gone mode of the views
to hide them from the UI.
Uh, so if you have a UI
in which, you know,
parts of the UI
is most of the time gone
or invisible,
instead you can use a ViewStub.
The idea of ViewStub
is to, um,
is to inflate
part of the UI on demand.
So a ViewStub
is an actual view
but it has a size of 0.
So it's 0 pixels wide,
0 pixels high.
It doesn't participate
in the layout.
It doesn't draw anything.
So it's really cheap to have
a ViewStub
in your view hierarchy.
And when you create
a ViewStub,
you give it a reference
to an XML layout file.
And whatever you call, um--
you make that ViewStub visible,
it will remove itself
from the view hierarchy
and insert
the inflated XML layout
where it used to be.
So here it's the same tree,
and in blue, you see--
you can see the ViewStub.
And now we have the same tree,
but the blue, uh--
the blue subtree
actually comes from
the XML file
the ViewStub knew about.
So I call set visible
on the ViewStub,
the ViewStub disappeared,
and instead we get this new, uh,
this new bit of UI.
It's also an awesome way
to create generic screens
without paying the cost
of having too many views inside.
And this is how
you use a ViewStub
It's really easy.
So ViewStub must have an ID
if you want to be able to--
to get the handle of it--
to it and inflate it.
You also probably want
to specify the ID
of the inflated view,
so that's the ID
that will be assigned
to view that
when you inflate
with the ViewStub.
And you also want
to pass the reference
to the layout
you want to inflate.
Now, on the ViewStub,
you don't need to specify
the layout_ attribute.
So you don't need
to give a width,
you don't need
to give a height.
But if you do, those will be
automatically assigned
to the inflated view
from the XML.
So it's also
a really easy way
to reuse an XML layout
and still customize it
with specific layout attributes
in a given screen.
So then in your code,
what you have to do
is, uh, find the ViewStub
and set its visibility
to visible,
and magic will happen.
And everything will appear
in your UI.
You can also
call the method inflate,
instead of setVisibility
VISIBLE.
The cool thing
about doing an inflate
is that it returns you
a reference
to the inflated view.
So you don't have to do
another findViewByID
to find the view
that you just inflated.
Uh, and I know that we use that
in several applications.
And that's where--
you can use Hierarchy Viewer
to see how other people
write their applications.
So if you're wondering
how we did
some of the default
Android application,
just grab Hierarchy Viewer
and start inspecting
your layouts
to see what exactly
we did
and where we used ViewStubs.
Another cool XML tag you can use
to improve your hierarchies
is called, uh, the merge tag.
Uh, it's a really bad name.
I couldn't find any--
any better name.
So declaring XML--
uh, layouts in XML
is pretty awesome.
But the biggest issue
is XML itself.
The problem with XML is that
you need to have a root tag.
You need a root.
And if you try to create
XML layouts
that you reuse in other layouts
or that you inflate
with the ViewStub,
you will very often
introduce a view--
an extra view
in your layout--
just because you must have
a root tag in your XML file.
Uh, so here we have an example.
On the left side,
you can see a pretty simple UI.
And the blue rectangle--
the blue rectangle
comes from my, uh--
an XML that I inflated.
And you can see it has a parent
that's also from layout.
And that's so useless.
I don't need to have
a frame layout
inside the frame layout
because, you know,
the parent frame layout
has only one child.
So one of them is useless.
The reason why I have
this sequence of frame layout
is because I included
an XML layout.
I needed a root tag.
So I just put
a frame layout there.
The merge tag can only be used
as the root tag
of an XML layout file.
And it basically tells
the system,
"Ignore me.
"It doesn't matter,
ignore me.
"All my children
will be assigned
to whatever parents
I would normally have."
So if I replace--
Yeah, somebody's using
Android.
So if you replace--
uh, and shame on you
for not turning the sound down.
So if you replace
the frame layout
in the XML file that you're
including by a merge tag,
then the hierarchy becomes
the hierarchy you see
on the right.
And we have one, uh,
one level less
in the hierarchy,
so it's more preferment.
It takes less time to inflate
and so on and so on.
So that's how you would use
the merge tag in XML.
It's really simple.
It has no attributes.
You just have to put
the name space on the tag.
And I wrote a blog about merge,
so if you couldn't follow
what I just said,
go to developer.android.com.
Click the blog tab
and look at the User Interface
articles,
and you will find more--
more explanations
about the merge tag.
RelativeLayout.
I think there was
a session this morning.
I think that was Justin
who talked about it.
RelativeLayout is often
a very nice way
to, uh, simplify UIs
and to replace
a bunch of nested layouts
by just one RelativeLayout.
It's very powerful.
I often use it myself to replace
a bunch of LinearLayouts.
The only problem is that
it's really hard to use.
Uh, and I think
on the Android thing,
I'm kind of the only one
who understands how it works.
So very often I get people,
you know,
come to my desk and are like,
"Hey, I'm trying to use
a RelativeLayout
but it doesn't work."
I'm like, "Yeah, I know."
[audience laughs]
And again, totally my fault.
And the problem is, uh,
it does work,
but you have to understand
how it's implemented
to use it
in some situations.
Um, and I promise
I will fix that.
I know how to fix it,
I just need to find
the time to fix it.
But I will.
Send me, you know,
letters of encouragement
and emails,
or threaten me.
Do something.
Or if you bring me cookies,
too, 'cause I didn't have lunch.
So if you bring me cookies,
I'll--
I might fix the RelativeLayout.
Anyway, I also wrote an article
about RelativeLayout
on the, uh, the Android blog.
If you go there,
you will get,
I think,
a better understanding
of how it works.
I show in that example
how to replace
a couple of LinearLayouts
with just one RelativeLayout.
And again, don't hesitate
to use the Hierarchy Viewer
and inspect, uh, the default
Android applications
to see how we did--
uh, we implemented the layouts
that we have,
and to see how we solved
that kind of issues.
Another awesome tip
that you should be using,
and I keep telling that
to application developers,
"Use custom views,
use custom views."
Uh, but usually the developers
are scared
of using custom views
for some reason.
So how many of you ever wrote
a custom view?
Okay, you're--
you're really good.
Thank you.
Any other ones?
Shame on you.
Um, custom views are awesome
because you have control
over the view.
You know how it's used.
So you can take shortcuts.
And you can
improve performance by a lot.
The problem we have
on the framework team
is that we have to write
very generic pieces of code.
And sometimes it's very hard
to optimize that.
Or, you know,
the cost of optimizing the view
actually ends up costing more
in the--in some situations.
So here--an example--
It's actually something
that we shipped in Cupcake.
So the guy who's sitting
in my office
is working
on the Gmail application,
and he was having
all those preference issues.
And I kept telling him,
you know,
"Use custom views, use custom
views, use custom views."
And he finally did.
And it's awesome.
So the item you see here,
um, an email.
So you have a check box,
two lines of text,
the--the time or the date,
and the star.
That used to be
a very complex layout.
So there was, you know--
there were
a bunch of email layouts,
maybe a RelativeLayout,
there were a couple of image
views, three text views.
It was a lot of things
for something that simple.
So instead, in Cupcake,
he wrote a custom view.
So that's now one view.
He's doing
all the drawing himself.
That gives him a lot more power,
uh, over the drawing.
That's how he can do the--
the different ellipses
in the same lines--
line of text.
And the preference
of the Gmail application
is now much better.
When you scroll through
a long list of emails,
it's a lot smoother
in Cupcake.
Android 1.5.
So if you can, uh,
write custom views,
please do.
And take all the shortcuts
you want,
all the shortcuts you need,
to make your application fast.
And actually, writing
custom views is pretty easy,
but I'll get back to that.
So that's the skeleton
of a custom view.
All you have to do
is extend the view class.
Uh, you need to have
at least one constructor
that takes the context
as a parameter.
And the only two methods
that you need to override
are onDraw
to do your drawing,
and onMeasure.
onMeasure is used to--
to tell the framework
how big your view wants to be.
And when you override
onMeasure,
you have to call,
at the end of the method,
setMeasuredDimension.
If you don't,
you will get an exception,
and it will tell you
that you need to do it.
Um, setMeasuredDimension
is how you tell the framework,
okay, I want to be,
in this case,
100 pixels wide
and 100 pixels high.
We'll get into more details
about that
in the next session.
But just know that the
dimensions that you indicate
might, uh--might not be
used by the framework.
LinearLayout, for instance,
is really good at that.
It, you know,
asks the text view,
like, "How big
do you want to be?"
The text view says, "Oh, I want
to be 600 pixels wide."
And the LinearLayout's like,
"Eh, I don't care.
You won't be 600 pixels wide."
So, you know, don't freak out
if, uh,
those are not respected.
That's perfectly normal.
Use custom layouts.
How many of you have ever
written custom layouts?
Ooh, a lot less.
Okay, better.
Custom layouts
are also awesome.
Sometimes, I'm sure, you--
you all had issues
when you're trying to come up
with the exact layout
you wanted.
We tried to have
some generic layouts
that are easy to use.
Sometimes they are not,
like RelativeLayouts.
And, in some cases,
it's actually a lot simpler
to write your own layout
than try to fight
with the default layout
and come up
with the one you wanted.
So this is an application
I wrote for Android 1.0.
And I wanted a simple grid.
I wanted a simple, simple grid
of photos.
So instead of using
a table layout
or, you know, trying to use
a bunch of LinerLayouts,
uh, to do what I wanted,
I just, you know,
spent 30 minutes
writing my own custom layout
that I call the grid layout.
That can only support
six items,
because that's all I wanted
on screen.
And it's very fast.
It's very nice.
It does exactly what I want.
And I didn't spend my time
getting frustrated,
fighting with the--
the default layouts.
Writing custom layouts
is similar
to writing custom views.
It's a bit more complicated.
Again, we'll go into the details
about custom layouts
in the next session.
Uh, but you extend
the ViewGroup class.
You override
the onMeasure method.
And the difference here
is that not only do you have
to indicate what size
you want to be,
but you also have to call
Measure on all your children.
So you want to know,
as a layout,
you want to know how big
the children want to be.
So you just go through
your children
and, uh, you measure them.
Then you also want to override
the onLayout method.
And this is actually where
you position the children
and where you give them
a size.
So if you write a really good
layout, like I just did,
you--you just do
the simple mask,
you know, consisting,
putting the items
in the right place.
Usually what we do,
and what you should always do
when you are--
when you write a custom layout,
is ignore the children that have
a visibility of gone.
Children in the gone state
must not participate
in the layout.
It must be totally ignored.
Uh, and it actually
could be ignored
in the measure--
measure phase as well.
But I didn't have enough space
on the slide.
Invisible children still
participate in the layout.
They still take--
take the room.
But they don't draw.
That's the difference between
invisible and gone.
And finally, memory allocation.
So I think the title
of this slide says it all.
Like, just don't use memory.
Sometimes it's difficult
to reduce your allocations.
And we have a couple of--
of nice tools to, uh,
to help you, you know,
remove allocation
from your application.
And the reason
why I'm saying this:
it's because our current
garbage collector
is, uh, I would say done.
Uh, but it works.
It's still good.
The problem is whenever
the garbage collector kicks in,
it will stop all your threads.
It will interrupt your UI
while it's garbage collecting.
And garbage collection
can take
between about 100 milliseconds
to 500 milliseconds.
That's a lot of time
during which
your UI cannot do anything.
That's a lot of time
during which
the user cannot do anything.
So if you ever wrote
a list view
and you're allocating, uh,
memory in the getView method,
you may have noticed that when
you scroll through the list,
sometimes you see
these little stutters.
And that's because the garbage
collector is kicking in.
Uh, you can allocate memory
in some places.
Those are the methods
when you write UIs
where you don't want
to allocate memory.
Or as little as you can.
So when you're doing
measurements, layout,
whenever you're drawing
something,
like, do not create
a new paint
every time you draw a view.
Like, just create a paint once
and reuse it.
Uh, event--events handling,
uh, those are ver--
can be very expensive,
and you really, really want
to avoid allocating memory.
To give you an idea,
the framework can send you
up to, like, 80 or 90
TouchEvents per second.
So if you start
allocating memory,
the garbage collector
will kick in really fast.
And the adapters.
So when you--
when you scroll the list view,
you really don't want
the garbage collector
to do its job.
So one of the tools
that we have to help you
remove allocations
from your application
is a--
is a cool API in the class
called Debug.
You can set the limit
of the numbers
of allocation--
of allocations that you want
to have in the specific
piece of code.
So let's say you decided
that you want to have--
you were writing a game,
and you want
to have zero allocation
in your drawing code.
What you can do is put that code
in your application,
and if--if there are
allocations
that exceed the limit
that you specified,
in that case zero,
then an exception will be thrown
and, uh,
you will fail fast.
You will get
the next stack trace
that shows you where the, uh,
the allocation happened.
Another cool tool you can use--
uh, I don't think it shows up
in the Eclipse version
of DDMS--
but in the SDK,
you can launch the application
called DDMS.
And in that application,
there is a tab
called "allocation tracker."
So you click on that tab.
You click on the--on the process
you want to inspect.
For instance, the home screen.
Uh--oops, forgot one step.
So the home screen,
you click "stop tracking."
You go back to your device,
or your emulator--emulator.
And you start doing stuff.
Uh, so I'm using
the application.
Everything's fine.
Uh, then I go back to DDMS.
I click "get allocation."
Then I get a list
of all the allocations
that the application did, uh,
during that time frame.
So I can see that, uh,
residents
have been allocated.
We created, for some reason,
a text view,
'cause apparently
we created dialogue.
So you really can see
every single allocation.
Even better, if you find
an allocation
that seems suspicious,
you can click on it
and it will give you
the full stack trace
for that allocation.
So you can see
what caused the allocation.
That's a very, very nice tool.
And I used it recently,
for instance, in Donut.
I discovered that--
I think it's in Cupcake--
if you, uh, long-press an empty
screen on the home screen,
it allocates 600 rectangles.
There's a good--there's actually
a good reason for that,
but, uh, I optimized it.
So it's--it's--
it is an awesome tool.
And you should definitely
use it.
Uh, finally, uh, be better
at managing your memory.
So how many of you are aware
of what those things are?
There are some good
Java developers in the room.
So I'll be really quick,
'cause we don't have
much time left.
But SoftReferences
are a special type of reference
in Java
that can be collected
by the garbage collector
when the only reference--okay.
Let's start over again.
A soft reference is a wrapper
for an object.
If all the references
to that object
are soft references,
and if the garbage collector
needs more memory,
it will first collect
the soft references.
So soft references are awesome
to create a cache.
Let's say I want to keep
a lot of bitmaps and memory
but I don't want
to run out of memory
because I keep those bitmaps
in memory.
I can put all those bitmaps
in soft references,
and whenever the system
needs memory,
I know that those bitmaps
will go away first.
That means that those objects
can disappear at any time.
And I'll show you
how you can handle that.
WeakReferences are--
are very different.
So they're still wrappers
for objects.
And if all the references
to an object
are weak references,
then the object
will automatically
be garbage collected.
I have--I wrote an article
on the Android blog about it.
So I will refer you to that.
It's an awesome way
to avoid memory leaks.
So here is, for instance,
how you would write
a simple memory cache
using soft references.
So you can put objects
in the cache.
Each object is identified
by a key.
And so we have
a HashMap of strings
to soft references.
So in the PUT method,
when we put something
in the HashMap,
we just wrap the value
that we're given
with a soft reference.
And then when we want to get
value out of the cache,
we retrieve the soft reference
from the HashMap.
And we have to check the--
we have to call the method "get"
on the--on the reference.
"Get" will get you
the value
that you put in
the soft reference.
But that value can be null.
It can become null
at any time
because the garbage collector
needed memory.
So you have to do
that extra check.
You have to verify
whether or not
your object is stealing memory.
If it is,
you can just use it.
If it's not, you have to put it
back in the cache.
We have several examples
of that in various applications.
So you should go to
code.google.com/p/
apps-for-android.
We have a bunch of open source
applications that we wrote,
and I think at least
a couple of them
use soft references
for memory caches.
You can--and those are,
you know,
standard Java classes.
So there are tons of articles
on the web
about soft references
and weak references.
So go to google.com
and find articles.
And we don't have time
to talk about this.
So here are some pointers
if you want to learn more
about everything
I've talked about today.
Go to d.android.com.
It's the developer website
where you'll have access
to the SDK, the blog,
the documentation.
source.android.com
if you want to know how
to get the source code
of Android.
It's very interesting
to look at our source code.
See how we do things.
And if you want to learn
how to use RelativeLayout,
go read the source code.
And the last two links
are pointers
to an open source project
that we wrote
that show how to write
good UI code.
And now we have some time
for questions.
So please go to the mic
and speak clearly.
No questions?
I must be very good
at teaching stuff, then.
Oh--oh, the previous slide?
Yeah.
man: Can I ask one?
Guy: Sure.
man: Uh, can you go through
the slide
for soft references?
Guy: Uh, yes.
This one?
man: Yes,
in this implementation,
since we put
all the software--
soft references
in the HashMap,
they are going to be collected
by the garbage collector?
Even though the HashMap is not
a soft reference?
Guy: No, um, the--
what's contained inside
the soft reference
can be collected.
The HashMap keeps
a hard reference
to the soft references.
If you can follow me.
So those won't be collected.
But what's inside
the soft reference
can be collected.
man: So we are going to find
the HashMap
full of null references?
Guy: No, the--
man: After it's collected?
Guy: Yes, so when you call, uh,
"get" on the soft reference,
the result may be null
because the garbage collector
may have--
the garbage collector may have
reclaimed that reference.
man: Okay, thank you.
Guy: Go to google.com,
read articles about it.
man: Okay, thank you.
Guy: It's more so that you're
aware of--of that.
man: At which point
should you recycle bitmaps?
Guy: Uh, every time.
man: So if--if you convert
on your list adapter,
you're changing the bitmap
on ImageView.
Should you recycle
the previous?
Guy: So, it depends.
You could recycle the bitmap.
But that means the next time
you will display that view,
it will have to fetch
that bitmap again
from wherever you took it from.
So what you should actually do
is use a memory cache
of soft references that contains
all the bitmaps that you have.
And--and put your bitmaps
in there.
So you don't--don't bother
about recycling them
in that case.
And they will be collected
by the garbage collector
if it needs more memory.
Uh, but the best solution
for bitmaps
is to use a cache
of soft reference.
If you know that you're not
going to reuse the bitmaps,
yeah, call recycle on this.
man: Thank you.
Guy: Sure.
man: I've done
a number of extensions
of view group
for custom layouts.
And there's a--
I think an unimplemented
property there
that says
"use child drawing order."
Is that something
you guys plan
to actually finish out
at some point,
because it's--it's really useful
when you're trying
to get semi-transparent views--
Guy: Uh, it's implemented
in Cupcake.
man: Ah, excellent.
Thank you.
Guy: Uh, before we take
the next question,
in Room 4,
Joe and I will show you
how to write
a custom layout.
So we'll give you all the
details about how to do that.
And we'll also show you
how to commit that code
to the Android
open source project,
so we'll take you
through the steps.
And we'll show you how
we review your code.
man: Yeah, when you're talking
about, uh, list views
and, uh, adapters and such,
you were saying the, uh,
convert view
is passed in the correct type.
But if the--
if you have mixed views,
uh, how does it know
which one to pass in
if you've got different types?
Guy: Okay, so that's
a really good question.
I didn't go into the details
because of time constraints.
But on the adapter,
there are other methods
that will tell list view
the type of the view
given the position.
And it will tell list view
how many types total
you have in the adapter.
So some of our adapters,
the simple adapter,
the simple cursor adapter,
take care of that for you.
But if you write
your own adapter,
look at those methods.
And actually, you will--
you will see very quickly
whether you're doing
something wrong,
'cause if you get
to convert view
that's, like,
not the right type
and you get
the classic exception,
then, yeah, you know
there's something bad going on.
man: Thank you.
Guy: Sure.
man: You had mentioned
about the allocation tracker?
Guy: Yeah.
man: That is not available
in Eclipse.
Is there another
debugging application
that we could download
that could, you know,
monitor maybe
the frame restraints
and other problems
that we can go in
and make sure that application
is running optimal,
or is the allocation tracker
the only thing we can use?
Guy: So you want, uh,
debugging tools for the UI?
man: Yeah, just to,
you know, just to--
Guy: Yeah, so actually,
that's something, uh--
I'm working on
on the side.
We have ways to, uh,
to get better--
we have ways
to get the frame rate,
and you can see graphs
of all the drawings...
man: Right.
Guy: So we have that.
But to enable that,
you need to download
the source code.
You need to turn on the flag
in the source code,
rebuild the platform,
and flash that on your phone.
So it's not very user-friendly.
So I'm trying to put that
in Hierarchy Viewer.
I don't know how
I'm going to do that yet,
but...yeah, we're definitely
thinking about it.
man: Okay.
man: Hey, you--
you mentioned, um,
about that when
you invalidate a view,
it unions the other--
you know, it makes a union
of all the other views
that are inval--
invalidated.
Uh, and we ran into that,
but our problem was
that we weren't calling
the invalidate.
When you change the text
on the text view,
it seems like that happens.
And we had, you know,
several text views.
Guy: Yeah, so when you--
when you modify
properties of views,
most of these properties
will cause--
will trigger a re-layout
or an invalidate.
That's because, you know,
if you call setText,
and...and then you wouldn't
see the new text on screen,
you'd be, like,
"Oh, hey, what's going on?"
And we don't want you
to call invalidate
every time that--I mean,
that's more work for you.
Uh, so that's why sometimes,
they invalidate themselves.
man: Okay.
Guy: And, you know,
just turn on the--
the screen updates
and you'll see why--
what's going on.
Yeah?
man: Hi, can you comment
on how you--
what you recommend to optimize
on the input handling?
Like a...events flooding.
Guy: Uh, okay.
So, I'm not the best person
to answer that question.
If you can find, uh--
Dan right here
knows the answer.
In the front row.
Uh, event flooding.
You know,
when you are in the game
and you get, like,
80 events per second
and your frame rate
goes down the drain?
Dan: [inaudible]
Guy: Okay.
So, uh, the answer here
is if you're writing
an application
that has the rendering
in a separate thread,
the even dispatching
will use as much CPU as it can.
So the trick is to put
a sleep call
in the...the event method.
Uh, it sounds very bad
at first,
but apparently that's the way
to do it right now.
But we are aware
of this issue,
and we've started working
a solution for, uh, Donut.
man: Will this, uh, forthcoming
Native Development kit
provide us with opportunities
to write more complicated views,
custom views, that might involve
complex animation?
Or will that be
very difficult?
Guy: Uh, with
the Native Development kit?
man: Yes.
Guy: So what you will be able
to do
with the Native Development
kit--
and I don't know
all the details.
But you'll still have to--
to write
in the custom views in Java.
But you will be able
to call into Native, uh,
to do all the drawing
yourself.
man: Do animations
and things like that.
Guy: But the Native Development
kit will--
will only contain, like,
the libc library.
It won't contain OpenGL bindings
or things like that.
At least, you know,
in the first version.
We want to get the APIs right
before we make them public
in native code.
But we know that's,
you know, it's something
that people want to do.
It's also something
that we would like to do.
And we're working on it,
and if you have feedback,
if you can tell us
what exactly you need,
just, you know, send us emails
and we'll look at it.
man: Great, thank you.
man: Hey, uh, so when using,
um, activity groups,
they have a tendency to, uh,
increase the depth
of the views a lot--
Guy: Yes, uh, so I blame
whoever wrote the tabs.
And we need to fix that.
I'm so sorry.
man: Okay.
man: Yeah, hi.
Um...
I've been trying to get views
to render offscreen.
So--maybe to use them
on a texture or similar.
Um, but we're having a problem
with, um,
the fact that I can't get
invalidate calls.
Because if I--
if I--
if I inherit the view group,
I can't...
the--the invalidate
calls the group.
It calls to the, um--
to its parent.
It's, uh, it's final.
And I can't--
So is there any way to get
the invalidate call backs?
Guy: Um...what you...
Yeah, so you want to render
animations offscreen, right?
man: I want to render any onward
views offscreen, basically.
Guy: If all you need
is a snapshot,
you can actually do exactly
what Hierarchy Viewer is doing.
'Cause I haven't shown you that,
but, you know,
Hierarchy Viewer,
you can get a--
man: And we would like
to get them animated as well.
Guy: Yes, so in
the view class, um...
So first of all,
to get the snapshot,
in the view class,
you have several methods
called, uh,
setDrawingCacheEnabled,
getDrawingCache,
and buildDrawingCache,
that will give you a bitmap
of the view.
That's actually
what ListView does.
When you scroll ListView,
it just turns all the views
into bitmaps.
Um, if you want
to aim at that,
the nice thing is
calling invalidate on a view
will invalidate
that cache.
And--and, well, the next time
you call getDrawingCache,
it will update that cache.
So it doesn't really matter
whether it's going to parent
or whether you can, you know,
override that method, 'cause...
man: The problem is that, um,
when--when a view
invalidates itself...
Guy: Yeah.
man: It tells its parent
that it's been invalidated.
There's no way for--
for me
to get that information--
Guy: Okay, I see, to know
that it's been invalidated.
Uh, yeah, actually,
there is.
Uh, if you, uh, if you...
set on...on view,
there's a method
called getViewTreeObserver.
It will give you
a view tree observer.
On that view tree observer,
you can add the listener
that will, uh, fire, uh,
your call back
every time the--the hard key
is redrawing something.
man: Oh, okay.
Guy: And that--you can also,
uh, be notified
when there's a layout happening.
There's a bunch of things
you can--you can see.
And you can even cancel
the draws.
So if you know that you're going
to draw offscreen,
uh, you will be notified,
and you can say,
"Oh, by the way,
please don't draw,
'cause I'm handling it myself."
man: Oh, okay.
Great, thanks.
man: If you have
an adapter, and--
when you build views,
you apply animation to it,
should you be caching
single animation
and applying that
to multiple views?
Or new instance of animation
object for each view?
And what are overall tips
and tricks for animations?
Guy: So animations--
you can definitely reuse
animation objects.
Uh, that actually works
really well.
And that's actually
what we do automatically
for layout animations.
Uh, so yeah.
You should, uh...
you should...
you can cache them
and reuse them.
And, you know, animations
are actually
that kind of thing
that you can put
in the view hol--
in the view holder.
And the next time
you need to use it,
you just, you know,
call reset on the animation
and you set it again
or you start it again,
and that should work.
Uh, are we good on time?
Okay. We're done.
Sorry, guys.
[applause]